et avant d'évoquer la résistance qui
semble vouloir s'organiser non sans
difficultés en afghanistan
on s'arrête quelques instants sur ces
nouvelles tensions entre les états unis
les talibans washington aurait violé
l'accord de paix de doha signé avec le
mouvement selon ce dernier les
précisions de mourad griefs envoyée
spéciale à kaboul pour rta
internationale
on a beaucoup spéculé au cours des
dernières semaines sur la constitution
du gouvernement fournit par les talibans
certains espéraient des compromis de la
part des talibans la formation d'un
gouvernement plus inclusif avec
l'intégration peut être deux femmes
comme le demandaient les occidentaux
malgré tout le gouvernement a annoncé
par les talibans un gouvernement
temporaire il s'est sûrement talibans
ils ont peut-être été encouragés par
leur succès dans la vallée du plan de
sheer le théâtre des derniers
affrontements le dernier bastion des
forces de résistance que les talibans
auraient été écrasées souffler et
contraint à battre en retraite dans les
montagnes
peut-être que ce qui a été vu comme un
succès militaire on a redit des talibans
le gouvernement intègre de nombreux
talibans de carrière quatre ministres et
vice ministres d'anciens détenus de
guantanamo bay ainsi qu'un ministre dont
la tête est mise à prix par le fbi pour
5 millions de dollars et qui est
également un fugitif international
17 je crois membres de ce gouvernement
figure sur le liste de terroristes ou
les listes noires internationales
les taliban afghans que les états unis
et promet de retirer sinon des listes
aux terroristes à l'époque des
négociations de paix entre l'état et les
états unis à toi la ville où tu as signé
l'accord de paix pour mémoire le coeur
de cet accord était le départ des
etats-unis d'afghanistan at-il dit sion
que les talibans garantissent que
l'afghanistan ne servirait plus jamais à
al-qaïda ou à tout autre terroristes
internationaux de baston des attaques
contre l'occident et d'autres pays c'est
le point majeur d'accord n'a jamais été
rendu public dans sa totalité il existe
des clauses mineures rien nous n'avons
pas connaissance
la première fois que les états unis des
talibans se sont accusés mutuellement
d'avoir violé l'accord doit c'était
lorsque les états unis ont bombardé les
talibans au début de leur offensive
éclair contre les forces du gouverneur
comme il ya quelques mois
les américains ont bombardé les talibans
les talibans ont affirmé qu'il
s'agissait d'une violation des accords
de paix les etats-unis ont riposté
l'attak débit les capitales provinciales
avant le retrait des états unis
représente également une violation de
l'accord
les taliban ont même fait de grands
efforts à kaboul et ailleurs pour
pouvoir espérer une reconnaissance
internationale
ils ont enterré leurs éléments les plus
fanatiques il n'y a pas eu les mêmes
mains de sang que lors de la prise de
kaboul en 1996 il est clair qu'ils
essaient d'obtenir une reconnaissance
internationale
ils ont désespérément besoin de l'aide
humanitaire international et des
financements qui ont été gelés afin de
tenir toutes leurs promesses à la
population afghane